dr. James Watson along with Francis
Crick discovered the structure of DNA in
1953 next Doctor Watson discusses his
latest memoir genes girls and gum off
which details his life and work in the
wake of historic scientific achievement
at the age of 25 this public lives
program is just over 20 minutes
I
hello everybody welcome to borders and
baileys crossroads virginia so glad to
see so many signs lovers out there
welcome when I introduce our guest this
evening his name is dr. James D Watson
and in 1953 James Watson with Francis
Crick revolutionized the science world
with the discovery of the structure of
DNA his feet one memo Nobel Prize and
has been described as the greatest
achievement of the 20th century but like
all great creative geniuses dr. Watson
did not rest on his double helix he went
on to help understand the structure of
RNA and continues to do groundbreaking
work and many different scientific
disciplines dr. Watson was a major force
in the creation of the Human Genome
Project he is president of Cold Spring
Harbor Laboratory in New York and a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences as well as the Royal Society
dr. Watson received a nobel prize for
physiology or medicine in 1962 he also
was awarded the presidential medal of
freedom the Coakley medal for from the
Royal Society and many other awards over
his long and illustrious career he's the
author of the double helix a passion for
GA and a for DNA excuse me and other
books and his new scientific memoir is
called genes girls and gamma off after
the double helix we are honored to have
dr. Watson with us this evening and
since dr. Watson has somewhat of a
reputation for being a bit of a
character we'd like to do something a
little bit out of the ordinary to
welcome him to our store here in borders
and baileys crossroads so ladies and
gentlemen please take out your song
sheets and join me in singing a rousing
rendition of the DNA song dr. Watson
this one is for you y'all ready okay we
love deanna
thais sugar phosphate and a base bonded
down one side a dunedin Thyer me make a
lovely pair cytosine without money would
feel very bare oh dear oxy ribonucleic
acid RNA is ribonucleic acid dr. Jameson
stop the jeans girl's hand and gama phys
to my recollection of what happened
immediately after the double helix the
last sentence of the double helix bends
on my birthday I had just turned 25 and
I was in Paris and you know I was kept
wondering whether you know I was no no
we were young and so I you know my last
sentence and I had known I would have
that sentence for a long time I was 25
and too old to be unusual and so you
know jeans girls in gamma offers you
know I guess an attempt to go on trying
not to 30 ordinary you know to still do
something and have high aspirations and
but it was caught up you know at the
same time I was very ordinary I needed a
girlfriend and so it's a mixture of you
know trying to
not be like everyone else and be enough
like everyone else so that i could get
over and so sometimes it worked in
sometimes it didn't work one friend of
mine who read the manuscript said i
should have called it the morning after
you know how see ya after you r ich8 you
know it was going to be a hangover and
so you know how long did the hangover
last and ask answer is about five years
we didn't really know how to move beyond
it and so the book is sort of a story
that
yeah we could feel satisfied too long I
gave maybe five seven hours on being it
talks and then I was really bored yeah I
was bull heart so you know and giving a
talk you know when you're bored you know
this the audience knows it so you know I
wanted to say something no that was sort
of the thing so I couldn't stay happy
and I knew that you know our thought
that the next big thing was
understanding this related nucleic acid
RNA and I thought well you know rnase in
the cytoplasm where you make proteins
and DNA is in Italy so somehow you had
the copy making RNA or DNA and then
irony was a real thing which and i
should say well what was the problem
that George Gamow and we read our
manuscript what do they say well is the
message from the DNA molecule is that
you know the genetic leg which is
written in four letters 80 g and c and
somehow the information must be the
order of these letters just like you
know the information of an English
sentence is you know the order of the
letters which are sometimes grouped into
words and so
we knew it was a linear language when we
wanted to know the nature of the
language but we know that the language
was the script but it was translated
into the language of proteins which
there were 20 different amino acids and
the essence of a protein as the order of
the amino acids so how can a four-letter
language determine a 20-letter language
in the answers it has to be combinations
four times four is sixteen four times
four times four is 64 there are 20 amino
acids how do you reduce 24 to 60 well
physicist immediately thinks he knows
how and so when gamma off sort of read
this he thought there's a code I'm going
to solve the code and he had amino acid
sticky on DNA and I knew it wasn't true
and he wrote a letter to Francis Crick
my i should say one sort of reason i
thought well hope i am I writing this
book because I know the reviewers were
saying sighs because the double here so
why do I want to be you know and read
all these reviews thing you know I'm not
unusual that's what was it you know I
really got doubt and boy so was this I
want to get off studies to be preserved
so they're in the back of the book there
really yeah one of you know both to
educate and entertain and if you know
entertainment helps you keep listening
to this paper go read the book so he was
a very popular himself writer of
about science mr. Tompkins disco his
physics series 1 2 3 infinity he was
very clever with them and he used to
tell me that his income was three forms
one third from George Washington
University one-third from his books and
one-third for working for the belter so
he would go off or you don't worry about
space travel and things like that so he
was a sort of he was always ahead of his
time whether the letters are our fun and
they were partly you know you can't
think all the time so how do you have
fun and the the preface I say what gamo
a sort of message was don't sort of put
off your fun too long that is you know I
mean when you're fishing you know who
you know hunting something have fun
every day in some way don't wait for you
know you may not get the girl so have
fun you know before so that was her to a
game off you know had these big searches
but he didn't know whether he would get
them he was famous in one physicist for
the impractical jokes so in the book you
know I want to dammit a camera off him
and beginning realize the you know gamma
off a fake the German nature it's called
not your business up and he probably
totally fake article so I can we think
you know can we fool the editor matrix
so this was you know what you did when
when you were born you know you'd say
well and but being bored is a good thing
I mean it means you're a free time yes
and you can use some of the free time
actually to think whereas if you're you
know who we have something to do all the
time you never think you just do the
easy as possible thing so a lot of free
time I had a lot of free time in cable
and you know that help and stuff and
yeah and Cambridge kingdom at that time
there are very few girls now there are a
lot of girls I think it's it it has to
go down as an intellectual side yeah
yeah no no I mean it because yeah you
can have fun you know girls get boys
boys can have girls I mean these days
you know and back in the update you know
there were two women's colleges their
way out and that you know the women will
call blue stockings and you know you
knew you just wanted to see him itself
you know so anyways I'm trying to forget
to figure what turned out there is a
place worse than Cambridge let's count
tech
heard wasn't those days there were no
women at Caltech i went from Cambridge
with you know a few weapon to Caltech
would not there was one woman street
yeah so it was and so young person read
my latest forget he just come from
Caltech it says it hasn't changed so
it's the one rate high you know in
colleges to go and have fun but but do
you have a limited amount of fun i think
you know they're trying anyways i tried
to you nose and the book has a lot of
characters maybe too many and but
initially we found the SS you said well
how many people really knew it was
important maybe a hundred you know not
then I mean by importantly is that you
give up what you're doing in use you
know you know start with DNA so almost
no one really changed what they were
doing a few and it took a while so it
was a small world and you could like at
the time
in 53
the other one person in Harvard interest
in dealing get some students there was
no one is Stanford there were a couple
people would work great so some people
can hire you traveling all the time we
who were traveling all the time just to
have something to talk yes yes we had
now there's you know he would say sir
20,000 people in the Washington region
maybe more you know even talk to DNA
about for those days they didn't him so
what the majority of people did is they
waited five years after we got the DNA
structure before meselson and stahl
showed the strands separated and that
was the prediction and so then the
biochemist had to give up an emitter is
important and so we got the Nobel Prize
for years after meselson and stahl
showed the strands theme park but before
then you can say well it's a pretty
molecule but it doesn't mean it but
after that you know
the opponent's came up now it has
another thing so there were no DNA
groupies yes not there are a few
appeared in the 60s other you know the
word Kate Hudson or something I can just
tell you it's the the Rolling Stones did
better than we do everything so there
wasn't just you know a mass about it and
so that's you know I'm describing this
sort of world where we know it's very
important when we made the discovery in
Cambridge no one asked us to give a talk
so we gave no talk about the double
helix in Cambridge so so Francis your
would invite people over and give them a
tour of the molecule woods in a no one
really euros has Chivas is this no big
so when we left the team bridge at the
end of it the model came apart and we
didn't save anything and there were
reprints from the paper and particularly
the one that contained the article by
rosalind Franklin and Gosselin near the
three articles together so now Gosling
who worked with Rozlyn a few years ago
said what I sign his reprints and
transistor there was a hundred thousand
dollars
so it's become but in those days you
know it's a has really stupid I think
trying keep any you know I knew it was
important but didn't act you know it was
just like you you don't invest so I mean
no investment in deal and so the D there
is a DNA model in the Science Museum in
London but that was made for the movie
that the BBC made in 1986 there was an
attempt before someone wanted to make a
movie and I persuaded Francis that it
was okay but it was a terrible script
and the BBC put together a good script
and made it without my permission but
they could and I was played by Jeff
Goldblum and it's pretty good movie and
rosalind Franklin was played by Janice
Stevenson who's a fine actress and so
movie is pretty good i objected to it at
first I really didn't like it because I
thought the central character is
unpleasant
yes whereas francis crick loved it he
was made a minor character in the movie
and it was the only time anyone has ever
described it was ok the movie was on but
I wasn't ordinary because I chewed gum
throughout the entire movie so you know
they made me interested yes so but my
friend Syria Gilbert who I dedicate the
jeans and girls she said but few were
unpleasant and then that's a sort of
problem by being unpleasant I wasn't
interested you know and other people
yeah I was still pretty you know DNA to
RNA and then you know girl but you know
other than that I I why I wasn't that
didn't make people smile you know I
didn't have good small talk
but so the book is slightly filled with
people I'm air for my sister saw these
people she's out there you know they
weren't much fun and so you know so
that's it then you know in the book I
have this desire for liking for the girl
but maybe you know I wasn't ready to get
married you know I wasn't ready to think
about someone else their problems you
know I had enough of my own you know and
the problem being in hook our name so i
couldn't be happy until i found our name
who wants to marry an unhappy person so
you are trying to scratch you know the
you know how we you're temporarily happy
but your basic mood is worried
so that's tough hey that's I guess so
yeah and then you could say well how
could I write a book about something 50
years ago and the answer is what I
thought it was going to write the book
and never did it was a good reason is
that I didn't remember it I mean to the
real details and but the girl Krista
Myers kept 68 of my letters so you know
sometimes twice a week heaven right you
know fairly long again one reason why
she might have thought you know I wasn't
perfect because the letters were filled
with science you know and sometimes
slightly acid comments about people what
you're just
so the letters let the book via because
I've shown the manuscript a number of
people and they don't comment much
because I think they don't remember
Frances quick way he was very useful now
he actually rather than the caught a
couple of mistakes in New where he you
know he there were a couple things he
really remember but most of the time we
don't remember what no you know where
you went to dinner for two years but and
probably these letters were the
beginning of my being a writer you know
I was interested in you know you would
sometimes say that is you know Wars a
short story you know something happens
and it's unexpected than you think it's
worth sort of surviving so the so
writing it was
yeah not as easy as writing the w's
because the definitely is a totally
happy story for us not for the others
but you know we want and this book you
know accepted unless you trap someone
was a practical joke you didn't win
because we didn't know you know where
the answer was coming from I write a
sort of long afterwards and sort of say
you know the answer didn't come up due
to technical difficulties were unable to
bring you the question and answer period
that followed the presentation you've
just seen dr. James Watson is the author
of the double helix the DNA story
molecular biology of the cell and is
latest genes girls and gum off it's
published by Knopf a division of random
house and you can visit Random House
calm / Knopf to get more information